foreign
[Music]
Bill Burr Shane Gillis Jim Norton Keith
Robinson Dave Attell Dice Clay and a
whole lot more took the stage last week
to perform at the 10th Annual Patrice
O'Neill benefit in New York City
to see a show with a tell dice Jon
Stewart Shane Gillis Norton I mean just
a killer lineup and Billy just kills he
kills it was one of the best out of 10
years I think Chris and me holding it
together I think yeah I mean those other
names are good they're pretty good names
and they're good comedians but
yeah it it was really
because of Rich moth the about section
for this year's event reads if you never
saw him live The Genius of Patrice
O'Neal is not something that can be
described he was beyond a Comics comic
for anyone who ever met him saw him
perform was on the receiving end of his
signature trash talking or simply passed
him on the street you never forgot the
experience white guys got a signal for
nice uh a nice booty and it's subtle it
doesn't involve like verbal content you
don't really have to talk you just you
know if I'm standing next to the bus
stop
over a white guy signal for nice booty
and a woman walked by
thank you
[Applause]
don't confuse that don't confuse that
with nice chest that's different you
know nice chest
[Applause]
uh black man uh brother black men turn
into ventriloquist we see a nice ass
we're like
the Ultimate Comics comic seems like
people's favorite way to describe
Patrice O'Neal Who sadly passed away on
November 29th 2011. to this day it's
still super common to hear comedians
sharing their favorite Patrice O'Neil
stories on a regular basis and many even
refer to him as potentially the greatest
comedian of all time Patrice Patrice
sweet who to me is one of the greatest
of all time for sure Patrice is by far
he owns a part of Comedy that nobody
else can touch there's other people that
have like categories where they're
number one or two that in the bench but
he's the only [__] guy who ever did
that and he was just about to get even
better and he was already just ex I mean
he would now be just everything oh my
God he would be if Patrice had a podcast
it'd be the greatest podcast ever yes
ever yeah he would have been he would
have been the king Patrice O'Neal is in
my opinion the greatest comic to ever
live He's also my last comedic
inspiration I have not been inspired
comedically since him
that's not to say that there aren't
great Comics there aren't people who
have done things that are very funny but
I have yet to see somebody do comedy
that I thought was a better version of
what Patrice did
Patrice was coming perfected in the way
that I view comedy did it influence your
comedy at all did he did he ever say to
oh man you need to go like this well
that way or
he used to try to do that to me in the
beginning
which is funny which was classic him
because I'd actually don't stand up
longer than him and he'd been doing I'm
sorry already pontificating
but like the thing about him I remember
him was like early on he was challenging
himself like going on stage and opening
with a different joke and like when
you're a new comic when you first start
like yeah you're a new joke yeah the
opening joke is your life rap yeah and
he's you know he was kind of doing stuff
like that but um
uh
um yeah yeah he was you know it was
[__] up
kids so we had it you know good times
bad times had to like [__] take
breaks from each other I mean we used to
take breaks from white people in general
and like I had to take breaks from going
down to The Cellar sometimes it's like I
just want to go down there and just
[__] have to have all my deflector
Shields up and be [__] you know
shooting Claymores over at everybody it
was a [__] War it was so stupid it's
really been glamorized that table it to
celebrate it was what we did was stupid
Patrice is a similar type of thing right
he was like a Cornerstone of comedy in
New York when people talk about like
people getting silly or being stupid
they go God I wish Patrice was here to
see this yeah Patrice yeah yeah the the
world weary kind of Swag around early on
man didn't like get along but we we
became friends because this guy was like
he was his real deal it was a real deal
God I wish he stayed alive I do too man
the comedy he would have put out during
all this [__] and we as well that's
interesting because I don't know what
would happen to a guy like him in this
context hmm he's not buckling I tell you
that I know so is that right I don't
know what's going to happen now the
Patrice thing that I live so Jay was we
used to go to patrice's house for uh uh
like Fourth of July or something he
always had a party at his house and so I
got invited and Jay and then someone I
got into it with someone else one of
patrice's friends basically and he was
like he told Jay hey Patrice doesn't
want Nate to come to the party and uh
then Jay calls Patrice and is like uh
well the context of this too is like so
Patrice had always asked me I grew up in
the South like I grew up you know
Christian in the South typical Southern
upbringing going to church all this
stuff so Patrice knew that and he would
ask me like do you believe in dinosaurs
and stuff and I would just go with what
I would say no I believe in him but like
it was you know I was like I want to
just say no like I'm not going to give
him what he wants right because then he
would make fun of you anyway right right
right so I would always do that
and so then uh so Jay calls him and says
hey uh our other guy says that Nate
can't come to your house for that party
and Patrice was like what he goes I
didn't say that he goes that dude
doesn't believe in dinosaurs you don't
think I want that in my house I want
that all over my house because he can
come to the party and I've lived My Life
by that with that I'd open-mindedness to
go if someone came up to me I don't
believe in the moon I'd rather talk to
that guy than a guy that does believe in
the Moon
[Music]